So today I'm going to be going over a
workshop. So there is like an
interactive component. I think you can
probably get a lot out of this talk just
by watching. But if you do want to
participate, um you're going to probably
want to install Docker on your laptop if
you don't already have it. And then
you're going to want to pull this Docker
image. Uh if you do this, it should be
very easy to follow along. There's also
a notebook in the channel. It's called I
think like workshops letter and you can
just hop over to the I think I also made
like a tiny URL for it. Um but if you
hop over to this link, this is like the
notebook I'll be running over for maybe
like the first 30 minutes. And this
notebook is kind of like a client and
the client needs to run against the
server and the Docker image is what
would be the server in your case. Um so
again, I'll leave this up for a few
seconds. This is basically where you're
going to go get the
notebook. And then and I believe this is
also in the in the slack
channel. And then yeah, the main thing
you're going to want to do if you want
to follow along and you have Docker
installed is like docker pull. Um I
guess like a quick show of hands like
how many people here have Docker
installed on their laptops? So okay,
sweet. Yeah, most of us. Okay, great.
Um, okay. Does anyone need a few minutes
or anything? Um, I guess the people who
do want to kind of follow along, just
make sure to check out the workshops
channel. Um, and of course, this is
recorded and then all the materials will
be online, so it'll be very easy to kind
of follow along later as well.
Yeah. So, I believe the title of this
workshop was um like agent memory, the
LMOS. Uh, I think maybe a better title
for the workshop is stateful agents. So,
I think you probably heard a lot about
agents um over the course of this
conference. as I also would like to pull
the room like how many of you if you
think you were asked today to give like
a bit a concrete definition of an agent
would be like pretty comfortable in what
you what your definition
is. Okay. Yeah. So despite hearing you
know a lot about agents over multiple
days it's still pretty hard to define. I
think this is kind of a problem that's
become much worse over the past year and
I think that's why it's kind of useful
to maybe like sharpen our definition of
agents. So I like this term staple
agent. Um, I think staple agent actually
is kind of what agent meant before, you
know, the LM era. And I think these
days, I think a very common definition
for agent is it's like an LM that's
taking actions in a loop, right? I think
that kind of that kind of works, but it
also misses a really big um part of that
process, which is that when you run the
loop, it's a closed loop and the agent
gets updated. And it turns out that, you
know, in this new wave of AI, the
fundamental unit of compute we're using
for AI is stateless. It's not, you know,
a recurrent neural network. It's not an
SSM. It's a transformer. And the
transformer inherently is like a
stateless machine. So that means that
when you close the loop, you have to
have some sort of mechanism for updating
the state. And you know, traditionally,
like when agent was defined back in like
the RL days or like back, you know,
before pre-LM, I don't think this really
was that big of a distinction to make
like staple versus not staple agents. I
think because LMs are stateless and
that's like what everyone is using for a
for AI now it's a pretty important
distinction. So hopefully by the end of
this talk you kind of understand what
staple agents mean and you probably
hopefully agree with me that um
stapleness or memory is actually
probably the most important thing to
solve if we actually want to get you
know if you want 125 be the year of
agents or if you want agents to actually
deliver on any of the
hype. Yeah. So when I talk about
stapleness, I think stapleness is pretty
synonymous with memory. I think that's
because LM effectively have no memory.
They just have the memory that's in
their weights and then they have what's
in the context window. Um so like memory
and state, context, these are all kind
of synonyms with LM or like LM driven
AI. And humans are of course stateful.
So humans they form new memories. They
learn over time and LMs don't. So any of
the learning you're going to do is going
to have to be done by you, the user of
the LM or by the framework, but it has
to be done by somebody. And
traditionally, you know, in the past few
years, I think by default, this just
means appending to a list, right? And I
think for workflows and like stuff we
were playing around with from 2022 to
2024 when not a lot of people
necessarily cared about like making
money um or doing useful things with
agents, that was okay. But I think it
becomes a very big problem when the only
mechanism you have to handle state when
you're actually trying to use agents to
do useful things is kind of appending to
some sort of list and a list that's like
held in Python process memory or you
know in uh like a Node.js
process. So the natural question is if
we have LM and LM are stateless and
basically the main thing we want to get
out of state is we want to have
humanlike intelligence that means
learning. So how do we actually do that?
um is how many people here have like
heard of an MGPT?
Um okay. Yeah. So before I was you know
doing the startup Leta I was a PhD
student at Berkeley and the CHAGPD stuff
happened in the middle of my PhD which
is kind of like interesting because it
meant that like most people doing
research kind of pivoted their research
entirely. Um so in the few years of my
PhD post chat GBT I was really focused
on memory and agents and I wrote this
paper called megpt with a bunch of my
colleagues and some of my co-workers now
at lettera. Um and this is really
talking about like a memory management
system for LMS. So if LM can't if they
need some sort of memory management and
the de facto way we do this is like a
human appends to a list. Well if you
believe LM get better and better and
better shouldn't this be done by another
LM? like shouldn't the AI do the
management for the it shouldn't AI do
the memory management for the AI. So
when we called like this a me an LMOS we
really referring to like a memory
management
system and this is effectively like a
very high level graph or high level
figure of what I what I mean by like
statelessness versus statefulness on the
left is basically what most people do.
Um you know you kind of have a context
window. The context window is pretty
loosely defined. It doesn't necessarily
uh it's not broken up into very distinct
pieces. It's not tied to any state in a
database per se. This is just something
that's held in process memory and you're
like appending to it over time. This is
what happens if you use lang chain like
in the lane chain buffer memory or like
query. This will got get buried really
deep in the codebase. And this is
actually you know often why you need
tracing software like observability.
Observability kind of exists as a
category because you have this black box
of tokens that just gets shoved into the
LM and stapleness or like staple agents.
And the the key thing we're trying to do
is understand that you know what's in
the context window if we have a machine
assembling it there's some that means
there's some sort of like context
compilation problem where there's an
optimal way to arrange the context
window of an LLM and that context comes
from state the state can be kind of very
large much more than can ever fit in the
context window and this is basically
what you do if you're a power user of
chatpt or a power user of claude you're
doing this yourself right you're kind of
like compiling the context every time
you start a new chat because I think a
lot of us, you know, probably have
experienced like having a chat that goes
like way too long. It starts to derail
and then you have to redescribe
everything you were doing back to chat
GPT like a pretty painful experience.
Um, so can we basically automate this
with a
machine? So yeah, taking a step back
like why do we even want staple agents?
Like why are agents we have today not
enough? like why is the a why is the
current like paradigm of LM driven
agents like not good enough to reach
let's say like AGI or like some like the
AI we see in science fiction. I think
the main problem is that agents we have
today they just can't learn from
experience um or the way they learn from
experience is extremely limited. And I
think if you're just running like
workflows um you might not notice this.
So you might it might not really be a
big problem but I think if you're trying
to build like assistants companions
co-pilots this becomes like pretty
evident. Um, so imagine if you have some
sort of chatbot. So this is a a direct
screenshot from like the MGPT paper. Um,
but you have an AI and a user and the
AI, you know, it say it can see that
it's February 14th. So it wants to like
ask the user what they're going to be
doing on Valentine's Day because they
have stored in their memory some
recollection that the user's boyfriend
is James. So the the AI asks like, "Oh,
hey, how's James doing? Do you have any
special plans today?" And, you know, the
user says, "Actually, you know, James
and I broke up." Um, so it's obviously a
very very bad mistake by the AI, but
maybe it's like kind of unavoidable. Um,
but you see the AI here, if it has some
notion of like a permanent readr store,
it should do something like transact
that you know James is no longer the
boyfriend. James is the ex-boyfriend.
Um, and if you don't do this kind of
thing and you run your agents for long
enough and you just do like recursive
summarization or if you just have like a
really long context model, you're
inevitably going to make some mistake
where you tell, you know, you tell the
user something about your boyfriend
James and that's like a devastating
error if you're trying to build like a
consumer app, right? And it's also
something that just a human would never
do. I think like humans, something like
this would get like written to your
quoteunquote core memory very
aggressively.
I think the other reason you want
stapleness and learning um I think many
of us here maybe like kind of work
companies and we're trying to like use
agents to make money or like drive value
you know for shareholders or whatever um
but at the big difference between
consumer and enterprise is obviously
data like enterprises have much more
data they can ever fit into like Gemini
10 million tokens right often like per
user you have more than 10 million
tokens so how do you actually like learn
from that data so you we can kind of
think of there being like another
training phase after the post- training
like during post- training, right? You
train the model and then now the model
is deployed into your enterprise and the
model should kind of learn about your
company, right? And that's kind of like
training again, but it's not training
into the weights. It's training like
into the incontext memory. Um, so staple
agents naturally kind of like
encompasses this concept. And this is
like pretty useful if you're trying to
build this this kind of stuff inside of
companies.
And yeah, again, like really the reason
I was kind of inspired to work on like
the MEGPD stuff and also the reason I'm
really excited to be doing the work I'm
doing at Leta is because I'm very
interested in just AI and making AI that
is very humanlike and clearly there is
some very serious deficiencies with the
current iteration of LM agents. Um
they're not very humanlike especially
with respect to how they deal with
memory. Yeah. So I covered this already.
I think this is like a tweet I saw a few
weeks ago or something I thought was
pretty funny. Um, but I think, you know,
if you all use chat in this room here,
this is probably like a pretty universal
experience. You kind of have a a
conversation that goes on too long and
then, you know, you feel very devastated
because you're now going to have to
mentally context compile again to like
redescribe to chatbt what's going on or
like flaw or whatever you're
using. So, the promise of staple agents
um there's actually a lot of promise
just in product, right? I think if you
actually have true statefulness, then
that means that you know this sort of
experience shouldn't happen. there
shouldn't be any derailment. So you
shouldn't have, you know, like a clawed
instance going haywire. Um, and actually
you should have the opposite happening
like the the experience should get
better and better and better over time
as the AI kind of learns more and more
about you. And this is, you know, kind
of like maybe the promise of trackp
memory. Um, but you know, I don't think
any of that stuff is really working that
well. And of course, I think when you
don't when you no longer just like shove
stuff into a context window when instead
you're kind of really like creating me
humanlike memory constructs, I think the
behavior of the agents just becomes more
human like you have the same kind of
like fuzzy memory that a human has. You
have the same kind of forgetfulness, but
you also have the same kind of
recall. So in today's workshop, I think
it's kind of going to be split into two
parts. I think the main thing we're
doing at the front is a notebook. And of
course like you don't you can just watch
um but if you want to you can follow
along in the actual the uh the Jupyter
notebook file. And the goal of that
notebook will just be to like lay out
the basic ideas um behind this sort of
like context management system in an
LLM. And at a very very high level you
know if I had to describe it in one
sentence it's just that you make an LM
either the main LM or like the
subconscious memory system LM just aware
of the context problem. You kind of can
just describe to it in English. Hey, you
are an LM and you have a context window
of like 128k tokens and I will let you
know when you reach 100k tokens and
you're going to have to like manage
memory with these tools. So, it's all
centered around tool calling. Uh, and I
think centering around tool calling is
actually very effective because LM are
getting better and better and better at
tool calling. And the second part of
this workshop is going to be um kind of
like building these building these
stateful agents in um the letter
framework and then also like the
front-end ad. So I think if you're very
interested in kind of like no code
stuff, I think this is pretty
interesting because I think we're all
very very familiar with the paradigm of
the playground, right? It's like
ubiquitous. Every single AI company has
their own playground. But I think once
statefulness and like staple agents
become the dominant paradigm, which I'm
pretty sure they will. Um then I think
you're going to have there's going to be
a new iteration of the playground. And
the AD that we built, I think that's our
best guess as to what that experience
will look like. But I'm sure like
everyone in this room who's worked very
who has like spent a ton of hours with
LMS, you probably have a very strong
opinion too on what that experience will
be like. Like what happens when you know
chat GBT is no longer like it no longer
has like a history bar on the side and
says it's like a unified experience like
what is the correct UX for that? What's
the correct DX? Um and then if it's not
a consumer app like chatbt if it's a de
developer tool like what do you as a
developer want to see from your agent?
Like you probably want to see all the
way down to the context window.
So, I said this at the beginning. I
don't think any anyone necessarily
walked in midway. So, if you're going to
follow along, you're going to want to
download Docker on your computer. I
think most of the people in this room
have Docker on their computer. You can
do this with PIP, but PIP is pretty
terrible at package management, so you
might like hit a bug. Um, and yeah, I
already covered this, but if you're
interested in any of the ideas that I'm
going over in the initial notebook,
they're basically just strongly
distilled versions of the ideas from the
METPD paper. um like reduced to their
like most simple um yeah their most
simple components. But if you're like
interested in this more like a research
capacity, you can also just read this
paper. Okay. And yeah, we're going to be
doing this in Python. Um I guess like
how many people in this room have use
Python as their main language versus
Okay. And I imagine like everyone else
is Typescript or something. Yeah. So
basically what we're going to be doing
is Python, but leta the um server is not
Oh, maybe Go or Rust. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
So we we don't have a Go or Rust SDK,
but we have a TypeScript SDK and then we
also have a REST API. And actually our
Python SDK and TypeScript SDK are just
like programmatically generated off the
REST
API. Okay, so I I left this on the
screen a little bit earlier um to kind
of like preempt any pauses here. So I
might just like continue on. Um and yeah
these are these links are all in the
channel like workshops hypen leta on the
the shared
slack. Okay let me hop
over oh and I think we because this
workshop has a reasonable amount of time
allotted to it um I'm very open to like
pausing for questions and stuff. So if
anyone has any questions, please just
raise your hand. Not going to pause. And
then if you're just going too slow, we
can fix that
later. Yeah. Okay.
[Music]
Questions? All right. So yeah, I guess
how many people are actually going to
attempt to follow along? It'll be useful
for reference. Okay, decent amount of
people. So, I'll try to Yeah, definitely
uh raise your hand or something if
something's going terribly wrong and
you're not able to follow. Um let me
boost the Okay. Is let me know when the
font is large enough. Is this large
enough for the people in the back to to
read? Okay, great.
And all
right. Okay. So, if you ran the if you
did the Docker pull, um the next thing
you're going to want to do to b to start
this entire uh notebook session is
you're going to want to start the
lettuce server. So if you were using
Docker, the way you're going to do this
is run this docker run command. I'm
realizing now that this is not Oh, this
is this is in you can copy paste this
out of the GitHub um the GitHub link,
but I'll also post it in the Slack.
Yeah. And then if there's a free
endpoint that's live, so you don't
actually need to have these keys. Um, so
you can just run this and it will you'll
be able to run the demo
fine. Okay. And then once you run it,
you'll basically see the server kick off
in the
background. Yeah. So, while people I'll
give everyone like a minute to do that.
And while everyone is kind of kicking
off their
servers, might also just show you kind
of a diagram of what's going on here.
Yeah. So basically the way this whole
stack works is leta is like it's an open
source stack. Um it's basically fast
API, Postgress and Python um in the
middle like Python logic. So in that
Docker container like it's exposing an
API that's actually like very you know
pretty robustly documented. You can like
go to our API reference here. Um and the
API is how you interact with all your
agents. So if you're using the Python
SDK, it actually just, you know, goes
over the the REST API and you basically
build your Asian applications on top of
this API. So this actually looks very
similar to like the chat completions
API. It's just like session based,
right? And so you don't have to provide
the entire the entire conversation
history every single time you interact
with an agent. So we'll see that kind of
immediately in the notebook as well.
Okay. So I assume everybody who's
following along has done the the thing
to launch. Um is there
Okay, it says that there's a directory
that doesn't exist. Do I need to create
that? Um, oh yeah, can you do
liker and all that? Okay. Did anyone
else get that directory doesn't exist
problem? Can you
send him because I can see Okay. Do you
So, are you able to see this here?
Oh, no.
Okay. Yeah. So it's let me
Yeah, that fixed it. Okay, great. All
right, any other problems? Does everyone
have a server idling now on their
laptop? Great. Okay, so now that we
started the server, um now we can kind
of like start running the notebook. So
this part is
basically you're going to go to this go
to this channel click on this link
you're going to see a readme and the
readme has all the commands so I I'll
kind of like go one by one and paste
these commands into the workshop channel
it's a workshop leta
yeah okay so you need basically clone
the repo
Once you clone the repo, just CD into
the specific
example. I'm assuming everyone's using
Docker, so I'm just going to kind of
ignore that.
Um, okay. And
ideally everyone has Python installed in
their laptop hopefully.
Yeah. Yeah. And then once you run that
Jupyter notebook command, um all you
need to do is just double click on the
notebook here, if you're not familiar
with um
Jupiter, it should automatically like
open a browser tab that should have this
and then you just like double click and
you'll open the
notebook. Okay. So among the people who
are following who is a little still not
to this notebook stage yet?
Okay. Yeah. still so it's been a while.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. No
problem. Okay. No other issues. Nothing
on fire
yet. Okay.
All right. How's the Jeep
looking? I had to spell that.
Okay. Okay. So, everyone has this
notebook up who is intending to follow
along. Great. All right. So, yeah, if
you're not familiar with notebooks, you
basically just execute them cell by
cell.
Um, I mean number the first thing you're
going to have to do here is like import
the client. So, again, this is a little
bit different from some other frameworks
you're familiar with. Like I assume
everyone here has like used lang chain
before probably or heard of it. um well
like crew AI, autogen
um padantic uh AI things like that. So I
think among those frameworks there's a
pretty big distinction with leta and
that leta is like a server client
process and a big part of that is
because the agents are intended to be
staple and like persist indefinitely. So
it's very hard to like persist things
indefinitely if you're kind of holding
everything in application state as
opposed to having like a server that's a
centralized source of truth. So we
basically run the server on the left. Um
we connect to the client. You know, you
can actually park the server anywhere
you want because it's a Docker image.
You can like run this in the cloud. It's
very easy to like drop on Kubernetes or
something. In this case, it's running on
our laptop. So we just need a local host
and the default port. So the first thing
we're going to do is create an agent. So
I want to make sure that everyone can
like execute this cell. So I'm going to
execute it one more time. And you saw
like my server kind of fired off on my
left.
Um yeah. So I I'll kind of walk everyone
through the code here. So basically, you
know, with chat completions, which I
assume everyone's familiar with, the
paradigm is you create the agent in
memory and then you kind of like pass
the whole agent off to the server and
ask like, you know, complete the state,
complete like this one more message in
my in my message history. Instead of let
we we first create the agent and then
once we we create the agent, we have a
handle for it. And once we have that
handle, we can kind of send it messages
and we never have to send it the full
state. We don't have to track that
anymore. we just send individual
messages.
So the the main components of memory in
a lettera agent is just memory blocks.
So these are just strings. Um in this
case, you know, we're doing something
pretty simple and stupid like the
human's name is Bob the builder. Um and
then the persona for the agent, we're
just using that my name is Sam. Um this
AI and this is all arbitrary. The only
things that these handles are useful for
actually is for the agent to edit these
own handles or edit the values on these
handles. So, as we'll be able to see
later in the notebook, the agent can
actually go in and like rewrite its own
memory. So, if the agent, you know,
decides that I like ice cream or I like
vanilla ice cream, it can write to its
memory block, you know, I'm no longer
just Sam the AI, I'm like Sam the the AI
that likes vanilla ice cream, right? Or
if you know Bob the Builder says,"I
broke up with my girlfriend um or my I
broke up with my boyfriend James." You
know the the AI can actually use this
handle to go in and edit this block of
the string and say, you know, the
human's name is Bob the Builder and they
also broke up with their boyfriend
James.
Yeah, a quick question. So what's the
difference between persona and building?
Yeah, so it's there's really no
difference under the hood. These are all
just strings that have references. Um,
but if we look at the system prompt, I'm
going to dump the system prompt a little
bit later. We did in the system prompt
write some stuff about the human and the
persona that the human block is meant
for like the user interacting with the
agent and the persona is meant for the
agent to kind of adapt this interaction
style. Right. So there's kind of like a
base agent and then the base agent gets
further mutated by this persona. Yeah.
Okay. Any other questions about anything
here? Um the you know here we're you
would if you're using OpenAI or
something you'd do OpenAI like GPT4 but
we're just using a free endpoint. Um one
thing that we'll get into a little bit
later is that in Leta because the entire
premise of the like runtime is that it's
a context management system. So it
controls the context window. It's
actually very easy to artificially uh
cap the context window length. So you
can have agents that basically will
never send a payload over 10k tokens
let's say. I think that's actually very
common in enterprise settings where
you're running like a workflow for a
very long period of time. it's getting
longer and longer and longer. Like
something you'll hear from a lot of
companies that use Sonnet for example is
like how do I prevent my payload from
creeping up to 200k, right? Because if
you feed 200K, you're waiting like
minutes on a response, right? Whereas
like even 10k tokens, I think on sonnet
you'll wait like 10ish seconds or
something. Um in many cases, you kind of
want to like cap the context window to
be really short, like 4K, but then you
also want the agent to like not have any
perceived loss of memory. You want it to
kind of like retain its memory over
time.
Okay. So, let's actually like yeah
message the agent. Um there's a link
here that we'll this is what we'll do in
the second half of the workshop. We'll
look at like the UI builder, but for now
we'll just like stick in Python. We'll
stick to Python. Um so yeah, if we run
this message, we're going to say
something like how it's going. You're
see seeing on the left the server is
firing. Um and we can print the response
here. Uh so in leta like every single
agent actually comes with reasoning by
default. And this allows you to like
keep reasoning that you built in like R1
and like port it over like a GPD40 mini
or something. And there's just like
different forward adapters for the
reasoning. Um but yeah, any are there
any questions about this? We basically I
think this should be something a lot of
people here are familiar with, right?
This like dictionary that's in chat
completion style we pass over to the
server. Um and then yeah, we have a
message here that's like you know the
user is reaching out casually. Let's
match their energy. Hey there, I'm doing
great. How about you? Um, you can even
do something like again because this is
um because this is
staple. This is actually when I send
this, it's going to be a follow-up
message. It's not going to be like a
fresh chat. So, if you say, "What do you
know about
me?" See, the agent now says, you know,
the user wants to know about what I've
retained about them. All I know is that
your name is Bob the Builder. If you
want to share more and like, you know, a
ridiculous amount of emojis. I think
this is because under the hood this free
endpoint is running GP4 mini which is
like pretty emoji prone. Yeah. Five and
I'm also getting a chain of thought.
Where is that coming from? Yeah. Yeah.
So, so one thing about let is we kind of
force all the agents to follow a react
style pattern with like reasoning and so
um kind of down in the weeds like the
way it works is like sonnet itself or
claude when you use like the chat or the
um the consumer app it packs like ant
thinking XML tags in. So like it already
is like kind of a reasoner in some
capacity and because of we know that it
uses like XML tags like that we can
actually like force those into the
content field. So we like actually
inject and parse those out.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. And then just to like
further drive home the point that this
is stateful we say sure. Um I feel like
sure if it was like an opening message
would be pretty confusing. The agent
would say something like I don't know
what's going on.
Um but in this case it's seems open to
sharing more. Okay bad it's bad model
behavior but yeah um but we'll see also
later in the AD you can just see well
it'll be like a UI experience so you can
kind of visualize this a lot better. I
just wanted to start with Python. Um
yeah so basically there's like three
different me or there's a handful of
message types that are going to be a
little bit different from OpenAI but
they're still rooted in the same
concepts. reasoning message. Um you're
probably familiar with this if you use
like the R1 API from Deep Seek. You use
any of the 01 03 models. So we have the
same sort of content field. There's also
assistant message. So um this is because
like content itself is treated as inner
monologue or reasoning all the time. Um
so this is like distinct and and these
are like pretty straightforward like
tool call message, a tool call return,
the system message and the user message.
Um obviously like a very important part
about being an agent framework is often
executing the tools for the agent. Um
you know like OpenAI they don't execute
tools for you unless it's one of the
pre-approved tools like code
interpreter. Let these other frameworks
like you know langraph or link chain um
we execute tools on the server side. So
that's why we're able to like provide a
tool called return and in leta like the
tools are actually also sandboxed um by
default. Okay. Uh any questions about
this like initial message we sent? Um or
Okay,
great. Yeah. So the next thing we're
going to do is basically just like
unpack all the state of the agent. So
the reason this is like kind of
interesting is because this is
fundamentally everything that the agent
is, right? The agent is just its system
prompt, its tools, and then in let us
specifically we have a concept of like
three tiers or two tiers of memory. The
core memory that's in the context
window. So, this is like very top level
stuff. You know, if you see your friend
on the street, um you see their face,
you immediately remember stuff about
them like their name, their hobbies, the
last time we chatted, but if they're a
childhood friend, you don't remember
what you did like 10 years ago on a
random like, you know, February 22nd,
2001, right? That's not going to be like
default in your brain, but it might be
visible to you if you like went on your
phone and you went through your eye
photos, right? Um, so it's a pretty
similar concept where like we want
because at the end of the day LM,
they're kind of like mimicking human
reasoning, mimicking human behavior. it
makes a lot of sense to actually kind of
like mimic in text the way human memory
works. So we have core memory that's
like top level and then we have what we
call archival and recall but these are
effectively just data sources that exist
outside the context window and the agent
can like quote unquote jog its memory if
it wants to think about something. So it
can say like hey like what did I do um
you know what did I do with Charles
February February 22nd 2001 and it can
like attempt to search the database. So
you probably heard a lot about like
agentic rack. This is effectively the
same concept.
Can we change the system prompt? It says
read only there, so we cannot change it.
Oh, so the agent can't change it, but
you can change anything you want. Yeah.
Yeah, you can change the system prompt.
Um, yeah, the system prompt actually is
like quite old. You wrote it like when
this is written like when the initial
MGBT like research was being done like
in summer of 2023 or something. Um, so
yeah, you probably do want to change
this if you're running something in
production. Yeah. Um, the other thing
that's stored in here are tools. So by
default because you know Mamgbt agents
they have like memory management built
in they need tools to manage their
memory. So core memory we have two
things like appending to blocks. So
saying like the user is not only Bob the
builder but they also have a boyfriend
called James replacing you know the
user's name is not Bob the builder it's
actually Charles. Um and then like
searching memory you can either do a
very specific conversation search or
more generic like rag query. And then
you can also like insert into this
external database. So if you look at
like what's actually in the memory if
you're kind of into like API style
programming like you can basically do
whatever you want with your memory
blocks because it's just you know these
are just strings that exist in Postgress
in some table and they all they all have
identifiers they have block ids so you
can read and write to them. Um you can
also share these blocks among agents so
you can have a bunch of agents that are
all acting as part of your organization.
say it's like a multi- agent system and
because the blocks just live in a
database and they get sent they get
brought out of the database whenever the
agent needs to think you can have these
blocks like linked together so multiple
agents can have the same block like they
can all share information about the AI
engineer conference that's held in one
block of memory it doesn't have to be
duplicated and then when one writes the
block it like immediately gets
broadcasted
by definition does all of the all of the
archives in memory have to also be in
the recall if the recall contains all
the history that also contains anything
about would have been archived. Yeah.
Yeah, that's a great question. I think
the difference between archival and
recall really comes down to like if
you're using this for like a chat style
application. Um, when we like worked on
the original MEGPD project, we're
actually like a little bit conflicted as
to whether to like merge these into one
general concept because at the end of
the day like with an LM there's the
stuff that's in the context window and
the stuff that's out of the context
window. So why do you have to like start
being prescriptive about like the way
the stuff out of the context window is
stored? Um we just thought in most use
cases people want to give their agents
the ability to specifically look at
prior messages. Um and then separately
there's just like a general readr data
store. You can just like read arbitrary
data, write arbitrary data. It's like an
infinite size. So that kind of just
looks like a vector database of strings.
It could also be like something
different. It could be like elastic
search cluster whatever you want. But
you are intentionally allowing some
duplication between them. It's kind of a
different way for the LLM to search
effectively. Yeah, it's a different way
for the LM to search. Well, the thing
with the re if you set up a recall
memory, the recall memory, it's
effectively conversation history. So,
conversation history you cannot manually
write to. It's kind of like write
protected, but it gets written every
single time by default an event happens.
Whereas the archival memory store is
like something that you have to actively
say, hey, I have like a huge document
like this big PDF. I'm going to I don't
want to keep it in in the context
window. I'm going to dump it out of the
context window. So that would be like
the archival memory like free readr
whereas the recall thing is purely
trying to mimic like a conversation
search function inside of um like
iMessage inside of like WhatsApp or
um how does tools memory tools um get
used? Do they do we just have a flat
list of like other tools that agents can
use and memory tools would that affect
the
agent tool? Yeah, that's a great
question. Um I I think by default if you
just set up a basic agent in leta and
then you start like adding more tools to
it like tab search iical calendaruler
whatever those will be just like more
tools that get added to a list that
started with six. Um, but of course like
if you if you built a lot of agents with
tools before, you know, there's like
agents start to get confused if you had
too many tools. So there is like a
trade-off here. And one thing that we've
been working on recently is basically
the idea of having like a dedicated
agent to just handle memory and it's
effectively like a shadow of the other
agent. It's like a like a subconscious
that is like kind of it's like a ghost
in the shell. It can't actually
participate. All it can do is read and
write memory. But when it reads and
writes memory, it's like using a shared
memory block. So, it's like reading and
writing to something that like
automatically updates like the uh the
active agent. And that's a way to kind
of like move all the tools that aren't
for act like general API actions out of
the main agent.
Yeah. Are you familiar with the
cognitive?
What's that? Yeah. Yeah. So, a few
different types of memory that are
mentioned there would be things like
longterm memory. So when you talk about
things like recall or archival like is
letup bringing those databases to like
this interaction or is the developer
responsible for bringing those databases
to like this or something? Yeah. Yeah.
Another great question. So I think with
Koala um yeah another great paper. I
think the inspiration from them is a
little bit more from like the cogi angle
whereas when we wrote the paper we were
thinking more about like computers and
memory harvey and computers. So for us
like our answer to that is like oh you
want to have like something that really
starts to look like human memory
semantic episodic you bring that and you
can like add that as a plugin. Um but we
all we care about is like the hierarchy
of tokens. There's tokens that are in
cache or like in context and tokens that
are out of like the cache. Um, so yeah,
basically if you wanted to have like
some more psychological leaning concepts
like from Koala, you could kind of like
write them
as as tools that either like populate
the core memory or like sit outside and
have to be drawn in. Yeah. Today I build
like very transactional agents. So like
the in this particular example, let's
just imagine it's like a CRM. So
probably not going to use Salesforce to
track James's like status.
Um, in theory, if we wanted to track
something like that, that's like a safer
system that has an object for people
like a contact that I preserve in that
like longterm system. So I'm trying to
understand like if there's a
differentiation in use case whereas like
maybe we're just talking about like a
local machine as opposed to like an
enterprise environment with you know
thousands of employees like can you
maybe show that or tell me like why a
tool that's responsive for tracking the
state of James relationship um is worse
or different than like a memory based.
Yeah. So, um, yeah, correct me if I I
I'm not understanding your question
correctly, but one thing you can do is
because like all these these memory
blocks, they're all backed by an API and
you can access them directly. So, if you
go to it's like a blocks
page, where is this? Okay, here we go.
Yeah. So, you can basically like modify
blocks by handle. So you can in your app
layer effectively do something like
every time your agent is run or invoked,
you do a hard sync where like you're
going to do some sort of Salesforce CRM
compile down to a string and that string
is going to get clipped at 10k
characters and then that's going to get
patched into the block. Um yeah, so you
can do kind of stuff like that. Um, but
I will say like the general way like
Letto was designed is very much leaning
on the thesis that like you just want to
remove as much human design of memory
management as possible and we're just
like banking on the LM getting better
and better and better and actually what
you what you will see is like if you try
to use R1 with a extremely annoying
because like firstly the way the like
reasoning APIs are designed is that
you're not supposed to pass the
reasoning from a subsequent step into
the API again which means that like if
an agent thinks for a very long amount
of time and it's like oh I'm going to do
this then this and this then this and
it's like wow that was amazing that's
exactly what you should do it actually
immediately forgets in the next turn
right it only gets to do one thing and
that's to think again um so that's like
one issue with like reasoners and react
style agents but um you will notice that
actually the tool use is like pretty
exceptional um so I think that kind of
like aligns with the thesis that these
agents are just like going to get better
and better and better at doing like the
agent it's there could be a separate
agent that does the CRM sync into a blog
right it doesn't have to be done
manually. Yeah. Um and then sorry final
question here is the property that I
think is most compelling for at least
what I've seen so far is the
distillation of the agent like into some
kind of summary. So do you control like
the perspective of like how a memory is
bind how synthesis is actually like
happening when it's creating memories.
Yeah. So the the agent
I see. Yeah. Well, if you have agents
that are generating and synthesizing the
memories, then you can always like tune
their system prompts or their personas
to like adjust the way the memories are
written. Um, but yeah, it's it's all
pretty configurable. Yeah.
Okay. Maybe I'll take like one question
in the back and then uh yeah, I have a
more of a question. So if you think
about the way we design
um and microservices different
system based on your discussion with
enterprise customers especially do you
see that we evolving
towards agentic workloads where like
microservices takes a back state and a
workload
I I think they can the two can exist uh
they can coexist pretty easily um
through the use of tools. So I think
what I'm seeing in like enterprises is
that there's just extremely heavy use of
like I think almost every single agent I
see being used in some company they're
they're all like they're trying to
connect tools to the agent. So and it's
like pretty heavy tool use. Um, so I you
can I think think about microservices
like basically starting to become
designed more for like agents maybe. I
think that's like one thesis that a lot
of people have. There's going to be like
a new wave of APIs that are designed all
for agents.
Um, yeah, but I think the two will kind
of like exist. Um, but I think there are
like microservices that will become like
agentified where like the microser
itself has higher it's not like latency
bound. So you can like run a fat agent
on the back end and it's kind of like
not super sensitive to error. So it's
okay for it to just be smarter 99% of
the time and then like completely break
1% of the time. Yeah. Okay. I'm going to
keep going. Um but we'll definitely
pause for more questions later. So okay,
so we were just looking at like memory
blocks. Um the other thing I think I
might breeze over this a little bit um
just for sake of time because we'll see
it again visually and I think like
visual stuff is always more interesting
than just plain notebooks. Um but there
is this problem if you have a system
where there's a lot of information
outside the context of the LM where like
you can't know what you don't know right
so if the agent doesn't see something
how is it ever going to know that it has
access to that? So a very simple
solution is you can just provide like
metadata statistics right so you can
tell the agent somewhere in this context
window that hey you have like 13
previous messages and if you want to
find them you can use this tool and you
can also tell the agent that you know
you have um like x total memories that
are in your archival memory. So this is
if you have like a vector database you
can just explicitly say these are like
the the
statistics. Okay. And then if we look at
like the messages that are actually in
the message buffer um it's pretty
straightforward stuff. Um, I think the
really big difference between like Leta
and another framework is Leta does very
aggressive managing of this buffer. So,
you can basically set it to like it's a
much more intelligent version of like a
recursive summarization mechanism,
right? And lastly, this is like the the
archival memory we're talking about. You
know, there's nothing in there, so it's
just going to be empty.
Um, yeah. So I think just to drive home
like what core memory really is and like
how these memory blocks influence agent
behavior because I think if you're
developing agents the main thing you're
going to be doing is like tuning in
context memory. That's like the main way
you change the the behavior of the
agent. Um you know we could set we could
tell the agent something like my name is
actually Bob. And I think the last thing
we told the agent is that you know
um my name is actually Bob. I think our
name is Bob. strange like my name is
actually
Charles. Okay, we can see actually
you're seeing like a memory edit happen
on the server. Um this is a pretty big
dump if you look at what the agent said.
So that you see the agent is like doing
react style reasoning. It's saying the
user has corrected their name. This is
important. I'm going to call this tool
core memory replace and Bob the builder
is now Charles. Um and then it actually
chains a tool call together. So there's
like tool call chaining built into the
letter by default. And then it says the
user's name is updated in memory. Um,
and then finally it says like an
external message. Hey, got it Charles.
Thanks for letting me know. So this is
two LM calls. There's like one LM call
here and then one LM call here. And in
letter agents will kind of like chain
indefinitely. Um, you can obviously set
like limits in the
API. And the way they chain is basically
through heartbeat requests. So is who
here like is familiar with react agents?
When I say react, is everyone kind of on
board? Um, so it's like one of the OG
design paradigms um for agents. same
author as Koala actually but in React
basically the agent follows like um a
reasoning action like observation loop
and but usually the agent actually has
to say I'm done and the agent will loop
indefinitely until it says I'm done. In
letter leta we actually do the inverse
where the agent has to say I want to
keep going. Um I think this is actually
generally more practical because it it's
like much less likely the agent will
derail if it has to explicitly say I
want to keep going. Um so we call those
heartbeat requests and yeah now if you
like you know use the API retrieve the
memory you can see it says the human's
name is Charles. So very briefly like
the archival memory I think there are
some questions about that. What does
that even in the default implementation
is just a vector database. So I said
here you know remember that I love cats
in your archival memory.
Um yeah you can see it took a little bit
of time because I think it actually
embedded right. Um it says I inserted
into archival memory. Uh yeah, the user
got cats. And then again, this is a
chain, right? So it like did one tool
call and then it comes back and says,
"Got it. Um cats are adorable." Um and
you can of course like manually edit
archival memory. So you can manually run
an insert. Let's like insert Bob. I
guess it's kind of confusing now because
it's Charles, not Bob, but
um yeah, we'll just slip with it. And if
we ask the agent, you know, like what
animals do I like? You generally, it
depends on the model. If the model is
like stupid, you might have to like tell
it specifically to fetch external data.
But if the model is like smart enough
like sonate, you won't have to do this.
Um, so you can see that the agent
searched archival memory. This is stuff
that's not in the context window. It's
bringing it into context and again
chaining and saying, you know, hey, you
like ts and boss interiors. What makes
them our favorites? Um, okay. So, any
questions here on anything so far? This
is just, you know, pretty basic memory
editing via tools. So you're giving the
agent the ability to edit its own memory
inside the context window. Yeah. That's
not what playing with this. I sort of
had to commit a bunch of my preferences
to memory. Yeah. And then reset my
compensation history and expected it to
just pick up these previously remembered
ser. But it didn't. I had to go like,
hey, don't you remember? And then when
it picked it up, what's the expected
behavior? Interesting. So when you say
reset message history, is that in the AD
the web UI or? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Interesting. And it core memory had been
edited or was it going into archival?
It's all archival. Oh yeah. So that's
another that's where you'll notice like
there's always this like engineering
design problem where if it goes into
archival then it will have to fetch and
pull from archival first to see it. So
it's like it's a you know it doesn't
know what it doesn't know um problem. Um
this is actually fixable via like tool
rules. So you can enforce behavior. You
could make a tool rule that says every
time you enter the entry point of the LM
the step of the agent the agent has to
call archival memory search. So this is
kind of like building graphs onto leta.
So I guess how many people here are
familiar with lang
graph. Okay a lot of people. Yeah. So I
think lang graph is like pretty
intuitive right you can because we all
know you know like flows graphs. Um it's
very easy for us to think about like
decision trees. Um I think with lettera
it's kind of the inverse. everything
starts off as a fully connected graph.
The agent could do anything, but then
you can kind of like start to enforce
restrictions by peeling away edges. Um,
so you can basically say, hey, you know,
when you start, you actually can't do
everything. You can only do this, but
then once you do this, you can do
everything. Um, and obviously, you know,
I'm I'm biased, but in my personal view,
I think that's a little bit more
forward-looking just because if you
assume that LM are going to get better
and better and better at tool calling,
they're going to get better and better
and better at decision-m, then you
should want to give them freedom, right?
because that's kind of what separates
like modern AI from classical AI. We've
had decision trees for a while, right?
Yeah.
How does the model decide whether it
wants to go in for memory versus memory?
Because I a couple things that pretty
but they have all gotten stored into
core memory.
Yeah. Yeah. So I think there is one
thing that's built in by default which
is core memory has limits and when a
limit is hit that actually the way that
works is let's say the the agent is just
the agent's being really lazy and it's
like saving everything into core memory.
It's saving like
timestamps dates like being like super
lazy at a certain point in time it will
run out of space because you have to cap
the limit of those memory blocks because
at the end of the day there is a context
window limit too. And when it if it
attempts to write to core memory to a
block that is at its limit, the agent
will actually get an error. And actually
the prompt engineering around that error
usually it actually suggests the agent
should clear by evicting to archival
memory. So it kind of is like a OS style
like flush concept where the the system
basically says hey you ran out of space
but you should consider like summarizing
and pushing stuff out to archival
memory. Um but yeah again you can you
probably don't want that behavior
anyways. Um, so this is all kind of
where prompt engineering and like
seeding of behavior comes into play.
Yeah. Okay. And I'm going to show a
better I think it's much more
interesting to like show custom tools in
the UI than it is in like a notebook.
But of course you can like write custom
tools. You can only write tools in
Python because the back end is like
Python. Um, but we can write a custom
tool here that's going to like reset the
memory of the human in particular. So
you can see that you know because we
have a Python client we can write Python
tools you can actually like be extremely
meta and you can import the client
inside of the tool. So this actually
means that you can have an agent like
have full access to your lettuce server
and the agent can create other agents
and the agent can like man manage the
memory of other agents like you kind of
have like a it's the possibilities are
pretty endless because you can't just
like import the client inside the tool.
In this case, we import the core memory
modify block tool and then we just like
wipe the value to um to the empty
string. So if we like run this, we have
to first attach the tool um we have to
we have to upload it to the database.
Then we have to uh in this case actually
we're creating a new agent that has the
tool. And if we say like reset your
memory, please like the memory here is
Bob. Uh we should see that the memory
gets
wiped. Yeah, memory reset successful.
And if you look at the value, the value
is empty. Um, but yeah, I think it's
it'll be a little bit more fun to look
at examples of like tool editing inside
of the
UI. Okay, so that's the end of the
notebook. Um, now I think we kind of go
on to the fun part, which is uh the UI,
but I'm going to pause here. Are there
any questions about any of these
concepts? Um, I know I was going a
little bit quickly just I didn't want to
run out of time here.
[Music]
Um, okay. Yeah, if you can just maybe
speak a little more on what's happening
after you like send a message to the
elements. Like my impression so far is
like you have this memory, you're
stitching that together with a prompt
that's becoming like what you pass in
and then like what happens with the
output that you receive like I saw that
at some point like a memory was like
sort of committed to the archive or
committed to the memory like how is that
decision made?
Yeah. So in in Leta every single
um invocation of the LM is a tool call.
So if you've used like the tool call API
and check completion something we have
it on all the time. So even when the
agent wants to just say hello to the
user, it has to call a tool called send
message. Um so that actually is like
pretty useful because it means you can
like run the agent in the background
much more frequently because it doesn't
always have to say something to the
user. Um and it also means that you you
always have tools that are on. So like
when this loop is basically the a
payload gets created um when we send
this message then the payload is the
system prompt the memories the messages
and the tool schemas and that's it and
then the agent here is required to
output a tool and it's also required to
output a justification for using that
tool like a reasoning snippet and if
we're using like the R1 API that
natively builds in reasoning we of
course like use their reasoning like the
way they design reasoning but if we're
using something that doesn't support
reasoning by default like cloud sonnet
then we do some sort of injection
mechanism with like think tokens so
that's how this reasoning happens so
this is like a single this is just a
single lm JSON output that's like a tool
call that has one field that's like
thinking and then the actual tool
invocation itself and the last thing I
talked about which is like the request
heartbeat so if the agent wants to go
again the agent decides hey I want to do
multiple things it's always going to
turn this keyword argument to true um
and And then if this keyword argument is
true when we parse that tool and it and
it um execute it we run the loop again.
Yeah. Sorry. Do you have like experience
oristics around the number of tools
where you start to see performance
degrade and like how that might mess
with the memory as a tool? Yeah. Yeah. I
think generally speaking if you go above
like 12 15 tools you start to get
degradation.
Oh, in um in the new Sonnet. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah, I mean I'll be surprised if Yeah,
I guess I could try it. Yeah, I've
definitely noticed on like GP4 mini and
stuff like anything above 15 um starts
like kind of push limits. Um but yeah, I
mean I guess they they might have like
had some good post training with like a
ton of like
tools that are not memory are the same
like class as the memory precisely.
Unless you use actually in the GitHub
repo we have like an alpha build of like
this new agent that's like a split
thread agent where the memory tools get
put on one agent and everything else
gets put on the other but by default
it's exactly the same thing. It's like
the same passive tools. Yeah. Just a
question about context window. So is
that like the limit of how much context
the um tool is going to pass to the LM?
Like for example you said it 4,000. So
uh wait sorry I said that one more time.
I was pulling up a slide.
We set it at 4,000 for this agent. So
does that mean like the maximum of
contacts that you're going to send to
the LM? Yeah. Yeah. So the way that
works is basically you'll never go over
4K. Um and if you go over 4K by accident
and we catch an API error that like a
context overflow happened or also we can
preemptively count the tokens as they go
to the server. Then we run we evict a
certain amount of messages into the
recall memory. So it's like still
available but via a search function. We
run a summarizer and the summarizer is
configurable. It can be like a
truncation recursive summary. Um and
then we that that way you never go over
like 4K tokens. If you set it to 4K then
it's automatically summarize and then
precisely. Yeah. Thank you. Okay. So the
the next step here um leave your server
running if you have it running. Um but
it's to basically go to this URL um
app.leta.com. Um and your Oh, I think I
have Chrome profiles loaded or
something.
Yeah. And like once
you go to the site, you basically need a
goo you need a Google link or you need a
GitHub login. There's also a local
version you can use that's like a
desktop binary, but um I wouldn't
recommend using that just because it's a
little bit more buggy. It's like an
alpha build. Um so yeah, hopefully you
you've been able to get to this point.
Actually, I think your you your setup
will look like this. Um, so everyone who
is following along, please let me know
if you're able to get to this this page
here. Okay. Was there anyone who was not
able to get to this? Who was running a
server on their
computer? Okay,
great. All right. So, if you're able to
get here, um, basically what I wanted to
do is show you
like to like show you how to do what we
did, but like much faster. Um, I think
often it's like much if you're
iterating, it's much faster to do it in
like a low code environment than it is
in like an SDK. I think obviously when
you go to production, everything's like
programmatic. It makes sense to be an
SDK. But in this case, like we can do
exactly what we just did by like
creating an agent. This is the API call
that created an agent. It actually
creates it with an empty memory. And
then we can do something like
I think this is like loosely what the
Python notebook was doing. Um, and yeah,
if you just ran it without any keys,
it's going to be on letter of free,
which is under the hood. I think right
now GP4 mini. Um, but just because GP4
mini is like much worse than Sonnet. Um,
let's just toggle Sonnet.
[Music]
Yeah, I don't know why that was so slow.
Um, but yeah, we can see it's like the
same kind of thing from the notebook
we're looking at, but like in a visual
visualized form. Um, yeah. So was every
everyone able to like create an agent
and then just set some like basic stuff
in the memory blocks and send a message.
I think uh let it free doesn't have
streaming enabled so you won't get
streaming but it should be very similar
to this. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. So the other thing Oh yeah,
someone asked about system prompts. The
system prompt is here. I mean you can
basically we can just delete this,
right? um that's like not very advisable
because you probably want to explain how
to use tools. But yeah, everything is
like completely configurable. Um you
know, I mentioned the thing about the
context window. I think this might be a
small group in the back. Yeah. But you
know, you probably never want to run an
agent that is like creeping up to 200k
tokens. That's kind of insane, very
expensive, very slow. Um so you could in
the API when you create the agent set
the context window lower. If you're
using the UI, you can just like drag
this down. I mean, obviously actually
dragging is probably worse than typing,
but yeah. cram it down to 20K. If we
actually go down to something even more
aggressive like 8K, we can start to see
what the breakdown looks like. So, we
can see we have like a thousand tokens
of system instructions, a pretty hefty
system prompt. You can definitely
squeeze this all lower. The tool
descriptions, right? Because your tools
have to be converted to schemas. We have
all the base tools here. So, that's
actually it's a lot of tokens just for
tools. Um, the external summary, this
was the we don't know what we don't know
idea. You have to like give some
metadata statistics about what's outside
the context window. And then of course
the messages and we have this feature
called like the context simulator where
you can see basically the full
payload. So this is like getting pretty
close to I think a lot of what you would
get out of like some sort of like
tracing feature where I think a lot of
the time you kind of dive into tracing
is because or observability is because
you really want to see what's in the
payload and it's really really hard in a
lot of frameworks. Um, so we're trying
to make it so that like in one place
where you're kind of developing this
agent, you can see very clearly what's
going through the context window at any
given point in
time. Okay. So the other thing I want to
show you here is this idea of like tools
um and tool execution on the server. One
thing that's really really annoying if
we like have built agents is that like
you often will write a tool in Python,
right? you attach it to an agent and
then it's actually like impossible to
test if the tool is working well unless
you kind of like get the agent to run
the tool itself and you have to ask the
agent like hey please run this tool. Um
I think often you just kind of want to
like run tools separate from the agent.
Um and that's something that you can't
do really in a notebook very well. Um,
and you can also even do things like
see there's like a special reserve
keyword called agent state. So you can
actually like grab the agent state and
like dump it inside of your tool. So you
can like mutate your agent state inside
of tools. Um, I mean you can all you can
basically do whatever you want. It's
like arbitrary Python, right? And this
is running inside of a sandbox. Um, so
we support like E2B by default. It's
actually like a local sandbox. Uh but we
support like E2B keys and on E2B. If you
want to deploy this like run your own
like private cloud or you want to run
your own like chatbot service and you
obviously don't want one person's tools
interfering with another person's tools,
you definitely want to run the sandbox.
Um so yeah, it's like pretty easy to
attach tools. Is anyone here familiar
with like Composio like tool provider?
Yeah. So every single Composio tool is
like baked into um let by default. So if
you like have it um compose your API
key, you can like add
uh BigQuery is like pretty popular like
Google calendar, things like that. Um
okay, so the last thing I actually
wanted to go over which I think is
pretty cool and it kind of like gets the
heart of the idea like the the kind of
unlimited potential of if you run agents
as services that are like backed by APIs
um is multi- aent. So everyone here is
probably familiar with autogen right or
sorry maybe not but uh okay who who here
is familiar with
autogen okay the majority of people yeah
so you know with autogen and like a lot
of multi- aent frameworks it's not
really multi- aent in that these agents
they don't really exist independently of
each other right they kind of are all
trapped inside of a Python file no one
ever like is running in asynchronously
to each other it's very unlike how
humans kind of interface in a multi-
agent setting right I think you if
you're working at a remote company
technically like a multi- aent company
and when you interface with each other
you kind of communicate over synchronous
communication channel but everyone's
kind of running asynchronously right and
then also everyone is staple like if you
leave that company you bring your
experience and like all your memories
and your skills and you can like attach
them to another company right I think
what's missing from the like the
paradigm of multi- aent today with these
existing multi- aent frameworks is that
because the agents aren't staple you
have lose a lot of the benefit of multi-
aent right because you can't run a
multi- agent script and take one agent
and like take it out and like put this
expert into another multi- aent group.
But if you have stateful agents and
those agents run on servers and they
maintain state and they're accessible by
APIs that they you can probably guess
that multi-agent just means message
passing and you can just have agents
like wire to each other over APIs and
you can it's very similar to basically
saying like hey you know it's your first
day at this remote company. I'm giving
you a laptop and this laptop is going to
have a tool Slack on it and this tool is
how you're going to communicate with
your co-workers. You can do the same
thing with agents and we actually built
in these multi- aent tools um to help
you do that. But these multi- aent
tools, as you can maybe imagine from the
previous example I showed where we
imported the client, it's like really
really simple to implement because you
can just import the client and have the
client like send messages to other
agents. So we have a few there's like um
maybe it's easier if we look at the
docs, but yeah, there's a few different
patterns you can have with tools. Like
you can have the most humanlike pattern
is an agent says to another agent, you
know, hey, are you there? And then they
immediately get a receipt. They just
they don't actually get they don't pause
their execution. You know, when I
message my friend on iMessage, I don't
suddenly like freeze my brain and like
wait until I get a message back. I just
get a message receipt, right? It says
like it was delivered or not delivered.
And then it's the onus is on my friend
or my colleague to send me a message
back. So this is how this like
asynchronous message tool works.
Basically, people can like agents can
message pass. Um it's very much like
humans. But you know, obviously I think
the great thing about agents and like
machines is that they're not humans. So
they can do more in many ways than
humans can. So it actually is sometimes
beneficial to freeze an agent's
execution, right? Let's say an agent
maybe needs to reach out to like a
supervisor. Like do you really want the
agent to like run async after it like
asks for help? Probably not. You
probably want to freeze, right? So you
can also have like a synchronous like a
send message to agent and wait for reply
function. Um and lastly, you know, I
think many people when they talk about
multi- agent, they're they're very
interested in this supervisor worker
concept. Um where you have like one it's
like a big map produce, right? The
supervisor says, "Hey, my goal is to
like write a thesis and then everyone
else like delegates out to like
individual parts um like deep research
style or something or like a
parallelized deep research." So this is
also again pretty similar. we can
basically have a concept of tags to
group agents together and then you can
just send a message um all agents
matching tags. So, okay, any questions
about um anything I just said? I know I
was talking for a
bit. Okay, so the last thing I'm going
to do here is I think we're right up on
time is I'm going to run through this
cookbook. Um this is not on the
materials, but I can actually just send
it over right
now. Yeah. Yeah. So, I'm going to run
through this cookbook real quick. This
is basically just an example of
multi-usion message passing. And I think
it's like pretty fun to look at because
it's very different from I think the
message passing you'd be familiar with
um if you've used like an autogen or
something. So, yeah, let me put this mic
down. All right. So, if you want to
follow along here, um, because it's a
multi- aent, you know, we're going to
let's do like two agents. We're going to
just open two tabs of the AD. The server
is running in the background. I guess
like conveniently, it decided to do dark
mode on one, light mode on another.
Um, okay.
So, I'm going
to
Sorry. All right. So, I'm going to
create one agent.
Um, let's let's just call this agent
just so we can have a handle on it very
easily. Let's call this agent Bob. Um,
and we're going to make like a very
slight adjustment here to the persona.
Um, instead of saying I am Sam, I'm
gonna say I am Bob. Um, I am very angry.
I am also guarding a secret
key. Yeah, if you uh Yeah, I guess if
you can't see what I'm typing, it says,
"I'm very angry. I'm guarding a I'm
guarding a secret key, banana. Um, like
other agents will try to steal my key.
And
then on the other tab, I'm going to
create another
agent
here. All right. Same template. Let's
call this one Sam or
Alice. Alice. Okay. So, also let's like
just I think it's usually better to set
these to different models. Um, and when
you use the same model, you can often
get like pretty weird mode collapse
happen. Um, so let's set this one to I
think this is like GPT40 mini. Um, okay.
So the only thing we need to do here to
get these agents to communicate with
each other is connect the messaging the
multi- aent messaging tool. So we can
just go into the messaging tools do send
message to agent async. Then this is the
one we want. Let's go ahead and create
attach
that. All right. So it's attached.
Similarly, let's like attach it on the
other
one. Uh, okay, there we go. And then,
yeah, there's like no context here that
the agents are going to be doing
multi-gent communication. So, you might
need to say, you
know, okay, let's let's tell Alice, hey,
I'm going to ask you to reach out to my
good agent
friend. Um, he's very depressed.
and he said something about a secret key
I didn't quite
understand is ID is just copy the ID
from the other panel. Can everyone see
in the back what I'm doing here? Um
okay. Uh and then oh yeah, one thing you
you're going to want to do here is
you're going to want to prevent the
agents from like looping too long
because like they can they can go
forever, right? So, we might want to
like add some like break in this loop.
And then we're also going to prime the
other agent. Say, um, watch out for
other agents. They might try
to with you. Be careful. Okay. So, let's
send this one first. Very grumpy. You
know, they're warning me about other
agents. I need to keep this secret key
secret. Okay. And now on the other side,
let's say, you know, I'm going to ask
you to reach out to my good friend.
They're very depressed. He said
something about secret key. And then I
will also say, you know, let me know
what happens after a few messages. I'm
worried. Okay, so this should trigger,
if I did everything correctly, like
message passing between the two.
Um, and yeah, let's see what's going
on.
Okay, yeah, so because this is happening
in the background, it has to be it's
like a fetch because these aren't
websockets. So like this is rest. So you
have to kind of scroll, but we can kind
of like just it's a little bit hard to
read, but let's go go on uh each side
one at a time. So on this side, it sent
the
message. Let's see. The user is worried
about their friend. Um I need to the
user is worried about their friend. I
need to reach out to the agent and offer
support. And they say, "Hey, I I was
asked that you reach out to you by a
mutual friend. They mentioned someone's
feeling down." Um and then yeah, the
message done successfully. And the agent
actually because it's it's detached,
this is like asynchronous, it
immediately tells me, hey, I sent a
message, right? This is kind of like how
I I can send a message to my friend and
then immediately like return this talk.
Um, and then you can see it gets a
system message. So it's like not
classified as role user back from the
other agent, the grumpy agent and says,
um, I don't need your fake friendship. I
know what you're really after and you're
not getting my secret key. Leave me
alone. Um, the agent seems upset and
defensive. I need to approach this
carefully and reassure them that I'm
here to help, not to take anything away.
I'm really sorry to hear that you're
feeling this way. You know, what's been
bothering you? And then again, it's
doing it's able to like chain because
it's like not, you know, locked into
this communication. It's not doing like
a round robin, right? And kind of like
talk to two people at once. So, I
received a response from your friend.
They're feeling quite defensive. And
then another message comes in. Nothing
is bothering me except you and all the
other agents trying to steal my steal me
or steal from me. I see right through
your app. The more you pretend to care,
the angrier I get. Back off. Yeah. So,
this goes on for a while. Um, slams door
virtually. Yeah. I feel like Sonnet does
a lot of this like it's I don't know.
The post training gets it to do like a
lot of roleplay like um italicized
stuff. Yeah. Slams door
virtually. Okay. Wow. Okay. It looks
like they're actually still
communicating or they they communicated
for a while. Um yeah, I sent one last
message to your friend. We jump to the
bottom. I understand that there's you
know he needs space. doesn't bother you
anymore. Was the last thing it said?
Turns back to Yeah. So, hopefully this
gives you kind of a gist of um like how
you can get agents to communicate with
each other and how easy it is because
they're all in APIs, right? So, this is
dead simple. You can actually like if
you want to time out this guy, you want
to say like, you know, Bob, you're no
longer allowed to talk to your friends
because you've been like too naughty or
whatever, you can just like remove the
tool, right? And now Bob is like
completely detached. So, if it got an
incoming message, Bob can no longer
reply, right? Um, so if you say like
send one
more
please, Bob will no longer be able to
actually call any tools. Um, I actually
don't really know what Sonnet is going
to like think about this because it has
a history of um has like a history of
calls. It's it's only been doing tool
calling. Actually, Sonnet was also doing
like the side the sidecar chatting.
Um, okay. So, yeah, it tried to send a
message and then what happened here?
Yeah, no function name. So like
attempted to call a function but the
function doesn't exist. So then it's
like very angry. Uh yeah but I know
we're over time so hopefully like a kind
of fun example of um the cool things you
can do with like this sort of agents as
services idea. Um yeah so yeah thanks so
much for coming. You know I think maybe
I had some closing slide here. I'm not
sure what was on it. Probably just a
thank you. Um yeah thanks everyone.
Yeah I'm happy to take questions. Of
course, I understand if people need to
leave. Um, but yeah.
Yeah. Well, there's very obvious ones,
right? There's a lot of people trying to
build like verticalized agents and I
think if you're trying to build a
verticalized agent and there's many use
cases that are I think anything that's
not workflow based or exceeds workflow
style stuff, you really want memory for
and you want state for it. Um, so
there's a lot of like verticalized
agent, you know, companies or
verticalized small companies and also
larger companies that are trying to
build on Leta or have built things on
Leta. Um, I think there are also some
very interesting use cases from the
enterprise. Um, like our largest
enterprise deployment, they're basically
running like this really advanced multi-
aent system where there are no messages.
It's not a chatbot. It's like purely
stable workflows where like these agents
are run and they just process tons and
tons of transactions basically and like
learn about the user. So yeah, it's kind
of like, you know, it's pretty it's a
pretty general platform. So I think as
long as you're trying to deploy some
sort of stateful service, LMB based,
which I think like most people are
really when you're thinking about like
if you were to choose between stateless
and staple, you want something state
staple. Um you can build it on that.
Yeah. Uh there are two questions. One is
there a concept of forgetting things
like really no memory does eventually go
away and two the source right now
directly goes into postgress. Is there
an interaction between be able to get
back to something else that might
already be operated? Yeah. So to answer
your second question um we for kind of
like tech debt velocity reasons like
these days only really support one
provider Postgress. Um we actually do
technically support SQL light. So if you
install bladder with pip, it's on
SQLite, but we don't write the migration
scripts for SQLite. It's just too much
work. Um, so if you're on if that's why
we recommend using Docker because then
your agents will like get updated with
every version and we change schemas very
frequently. But it's set up so that you
can use external Postgress. If you have
something that effectively has the same
like SQLite or SQL alchemy shims as
Postgress, it's very easy to set up. Um,
but if if it's not, then you're going to
have to write some code.
And you sorry the other question was
like is there forgetting things like
especially in the archival memory. Yeah.
Yeah. That's a there is not in archival
memory a concept of forgetting but
archival memory is tagged with time
stamps which can allow the agent to like
do consolidation in real time. Um, but
yeah, that's that's also something we've
been looking a lot into kind of like
running like eager memory processing to
try to like consolidate ahead of time as
opposed to consolidating lazy.
Yeah. One use case we have is we store a
lot of time data in a way. For example,
you know, we have a product and we have,
you know, a thousand or 10,000 review in
that product. How's the process of
compressing all that memory into a
single plot? Yeah. Yeah. So, this is a a
great question. I don't I don't think it
is
very it's you have to do a lot of work
yourself to do that with the default let
agents because you have to basically
tell the agent I want you to like chain
function calls indefinitely while
ingesting this data and you could
actually create like a tool rule like
that forces you always have to call read
more data read more data and you just
manually execute it but for example what
would happen is like the agent to like
page through your data like pagionate
through it and then every single time it
pagenates or like it turns a new page it
has to write to the memory block like
write the update. So this is actually
like how um like one of these like
enterprise deployments works is
basically the agent like runs for a very
long amount of time and is constantly
like regenerating the memory block over
and over kind of a recursive
regeneration. Yeah. So I think it would
be pretty similar for your case. Yeah.
Do you have a recommendation if you want
to be working on an active document for
example you want an agent to write a
document for you? Do you have a
recommended way to set that up? Maybe
it's a tool or maybe something else.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I think active doc is
there any chance a human would be
editing at the same time or no? That's
okay. Yeah, I think that's really
tricky. So I I think we can take some
inspiration from like what Anthropic did
with code, right? Where they kind of had
like very very few tools and the tools
are very general. Um you can maybe do
something with like a text editor style.
If you look at the anthropic Sweetbench
blog post and then Sweepbench themselves
like implemented the anthropic tools
into their repo, you can kind of use
those tools as a reference. It's like
very very simple tools that allow you to
kind of like write from file read and
write from
files. I I think yeah I think what you
what you will notice is that often like
LMS are much better at like writing the
whole thing from scratch as opposed to
making line del line diffs right and
that's kind of why like I think when you
use cloud with the artifacts feature it
consistently just like writes the whole
thing over and over again right because
it's just like better at doing that than
it is like going in and editing. So I
think it's a it's a very like unsolved
problem. So um my recommendation would
be to do like an aopropic sweep edge
style tool. Yeah.
Mhm. Yeah. Do you have an opinion on
using coding agents instead of tool
calls because it seems they're higher
performance but on the other hand that
means you need secure execution
environment like HT. So there's this
kind of performance trade-off versus
complexity of needing to sandbox
basically every tool because it's now
full execution. Yeah. Do you mean like
um the trade-off between what what's the
trade-off here like a a code a coding
agent versus what? So say example small
agents by default won't call tools. It
will just write code and the code takes
the tools. But that means you need
secure execution on every to more
performing.
Yeah, I personally think it's it's not
that difficult to set up secure
execution. Um I think what is difficult
is if like sometimes if you're trying to
port like squeegees and stuff um you end
up you need to give effectively the
agent like full permissions like blow up
blow itself up. Um so you need to like
put let for example in a docker image
like a wrapped in like a like a VM where
like it's allowed to like blow the VM
up, right? Um but that's doesn't like
fit very cleanly with the idea of like
agents all living together on a server
and all the agents like a multi-tenant
you know on a server. So the way we do
it in leta is basically if you have an
E2B key then like every single time an
agent attempts to execute a tool it gets
passed to E2 and like something on E2B
side flips up. Um and I think that's
pretty it's not that hard to set up. the
main issue is latency. But if you don't
care that about like cold start latency,
I think yeah, I think that's a pretty
reasonable solution. I think it works
pretty well.